we start with breaking news as a damning
reporters found children in the care of
lambeth council
were subjected to decades of cruelty and
sexual abuse
the independent inquiry looked at the
scale and nature of the sexual abuse
over several decades
dating back to the 1960s it's also
calling for a criminal investigation to
be considered
into the handling of the case of a child
who died in care
well the report found that one of the
council's biggest care homes
shirley oaks received allegations of
sexual abuse against
177 members of staff or individuals
connected with the home it found that
these involved at least
529 former residents by june 2020 the
council had complaints of sexual abuse
from 705
former residents despite this over 40
years the council only disciplined one
senior employee
for their part in the catalogue of
sexual abuse
well let's cross live to south london
where we can talk to our correspondent
ali fortescue and ali
700 uh people allege that they were
abused there as children
180 potential different abusers the
scale of this
is just jaw dropping isn't it
you're absolutely right i mean a real
sense today of the scale of the abuse
against hundreds of children over
decades
under the care of lambeth council this
is the report
it's just come out it's 211 pages long
it looks at five different care homes
but as you said the focus
really on shirley oaks this was one of
the biggest care homes
in lambeth up to 390 children under 17
there
at any one time and it said it was a
brutal place where violence
and sexual assaults were allowed to
flourish as you said it found
allegations
of sexual abuse against 177
members of staff and people linked to
the home and it said and i quote that
there were levels of cruelty
and sexual abuse that are hard to
comprehend there were
so many stories that we heard over the
course
of this report the girl who said that
she had been raped more than
500 times by older people at their care
home
the boy who'd been found dead in a
bathroom and
the coroner in that case who had never
been told that that
boy had said that he'd been sexually
abused
by someone who was meant to be caring
for him at the home his so-called
house father someone that was meant to
be looking after him and today
this inquiry is asking for
the police to look again at that they
are asking for a criminal investigation
to be opened into that case and making a
number of other recommendations
as well including vetting processes for
uh current foster carers they want more
safeguard training for elected
counselors but really
they say that the scale of abuse will
never truly be known and is very likely
to be
much worse and has been recorded